ah ah
chelou de l'enfant
mangez ceci est mon corps
oui et buvez
ceci est mon sang hwa
on ne reste pas longtemps n oubliez pas
surtout aimez-vous nsa dans l'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour un père non non
m
qu'est ce qui la fait pas il a bu une
bière
c'est ça votre ville et vous rendiez
décérébrés qui remue encore potins m'a
battu voire six ans de pouvoir a pas pu
venir
c'est con ça paie simone ans pareil pour
votre chien est de reconnaître que celle
là bas là la fille et les cheveux noirs
si elle venait chez moi il n'y aurait
pas dans la baignoire ça me parlait pas
ce recueil c'est l'appel de jésus elle
surtout une ribot du coup
very bad et 10 yens j'ai vu trois buts à
ce sujet guillaume tu sais qu'il a fondé
l'école péripatéticienne non aristote et
je crois que je peux dire salon du
bourget dix jours
[Applaudissements]